Democrat Senator Bob Menendez has been
indicted on federal corruption charges
according to the Department of Justice
the senator took hundreds of thousands
of dollars of bribes from a handful of
New Jersey businessmen the bribes
according to the indictment included
quote Cash Gold payments toward a home
mortgage compensation for a low or
no-show job a luxury vehicle and other
things of value and federal
investigators have pretty good evidence
for the charges
since they reportedly found gold bars
and cash stuffed throughout the
Senator's home and hidden in his
clothing
the purpose of the bribes was not only
to enrich these three businessmen but
also apparently to benefit Egypt which
makes sense since Menendez was until
just a couple days ago the chairman of
the Senate Foreign Relations Committee
the same position that coincidentally
Joe Biden held until he became vice
president
it also makes sense that the doj would
go after Menendez now not because his
crimes are particularly new or urgent
prosecutors have known about them since
at least 2015 when Menendez was first
prosecuted for this sort of thing though
that case ended in a mistrial and in
fact menendez's corruption has been
widely known and even a Washington punch
line for many years the man is obviously
corrupt but so is the doj which is
Prosecuting Menendez now to take the
heat off of Joe Biden who committed the
exact same crimes on a much larger scale
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers good
ranchers which I had at dinner last
night had a juicy delicious rib eye and
it was great as always get great meals
at a secure price and 25 bucks off your
order with code Knowles Kennedy Valley
yes go to go ranchers.com use code
Knowles today Ukraine President Vladimir
zielinski has just hired a witch an
actual witch to be an ambassador we'll
get to that in one second first though
I gotta stick to the corruption in
Washington for just a moment a friend
pointed out about the Menendez
indictment that
he almost didn't believe the charges
because that is how low up an opinion he
has of the Department of Justice so the
doj is just so corrupt I almost think
Menendez might be innocent but it's not
an either or Menendez is obviously
corrupt and we have all known this for a
decade at least
and the doj is also corrupt we've known
this for at least seven eight years now
and it is clear as day to me that where
those two corrupt entities meet and why
we're seeing this explode right now is
because of Biden because Joe Biden did
exactly the same thing that Menendez did
at a much larger scale he took bribes
Hunter was shaken down foreign entities
governments and semi-private actors all
around the world while Joe was in a very
serious position of power Hunter was
flying on Air Force two to do it some of
the time Joe was involved on the phone
calls writing emails under pseudonyms
sometimes handwritten notes to Hunter's
crooked Associates and what was the end
game the end game was selling American
influence because he was in a position
of power in the case of Menendez he was
just a senator on the Foreign Relations
Committee in the case of Biden he had
been on the Foreign Relations Committee
and then was the Vice President in
charge of Ukraine affairs
Menendez was getting hundreds of
thousands of dollars the bidens were
raking in millions
so why does Menendez get pinched now
what's because there's a ton of heat on
Joe you we've got terabytes worth of
evidence that he did this and so we've
got to have a little distraction there's
virtually no news story that comes out
of Washington that was not intentionally
placed there doesn't mean that
everything's fake doesn't mean that
everything is a conspiracy theory but it
means that the editors the leakers from
within the government the political
actors who are making the news they they
do so with multiple purposes in mind
nothing is merely accidental and very
few things are caused merely by
circumstance there's even more evidence
of Joe Biden's corruption we have an IRS
agent now who's come out and said on the
record that the Department of Justice
blocked prosecutor David Weiss from
charging Hunter Biden David Weiss is now
the special counsel who's going after
Hunter previously though he was just
running the doj investigation into it
and you now have an IRS whistleblower
who is saying that that Weiss was
stopped by the OJ from charging Hunter
this contradicts Joe Biden's attorney
general Merritt Garland
Garland said he was given he David Weiss
was given complete authority to make all
decisions on his own we've now got
multiple whistleblowers saying that was
not the case which means that what we
now need is an investigation of the
investigations into Hunter Biden which
is what we had previously we had an
investigation into the investigations of
Donald Trump that's what John Durham was
up to investigating how the
investigations took place and what what
the ruling classes banking on here is
this is just going to be so complicated
it's going to go on for so long that
people are going to stop caring and
that's probably true so the thing to
look for now
is we've got whistleblowing on the
investigation into the corruption
because the investigation wasn't allowed
to actually do its job what you can
expect now is a lot more distractions a
la bob Menendez we're still a year out
we're still more than a year out from
the 2024 presidential election they're
going to be so many more little
butterflies sent out to distract us now
some government actions unlike the
hunter investigation are not being
stymied and blocked some government
operations are continuing without
impediment one of which of course is
the funding of the war in Ukraine
the Pentagon has just come out DOD
spokesman Chris Sherwood has come out
and said operation Atlantic resolve
is an accepted activity under a
government lapse in Appropriations
of course
the funding of the war in Ukraine has
basically nothing to do with Congress
Congress is still pretending that
Congress still has the power of the
purse strings Congress is still
pretended that that would be the House
of Representatives the Senate is still
pretending that it has the power to
ratify treaties and make war but that's
not really true in practice in practice
the house can whine and cry all at once
the Seneca wine and cry all at once the
Pentagon is the executive branch is
still going to continue to conduct this
war in Ukraine and they're going to keep
funding it don't forget back just a few
months ago
we had that news story six billion
dollars discovered
uh it must have been lost under a couch
cushion it was meant for Ukraine but
they never got it so we're just going to
give them the 6 billion right now and
what was that story they didn't Discover
it under a couch cushion what they did
was Expos facto they changed the prices
of the arms that we had sent to Ukraine
because they didn't want to go through
the full political process of getting
more money allocated to Ukraine so they
said oh no actually we're going to go
back you do some magical accounting all
the guns and bullets and everything else
we sent over there actually it was
cheaper than we said it was and because
we'd already allocated x amount of money
for Ukraine that means that we got 6
billion left over okay better send that
over to them what are they going to do
even if they were stymied from sending
any new amounts of money over there they
would just go back and change the prices
again and they'd use some magical
accounting and no matter what happens if
that government is completely shut down
I promise you
the war funding will continue because a
government shutdown doesn't actually
shut down the government
because the people and the people's
Representatives have significantly less
control over the government than many of
them flatter themselves as having
speaking of our leaders in Washington
and this war funding Rand Paul
the obstinate Republican senator has
said that he is going to hold up funding
over the Ukraine war
Rand Paul says he will move to hold up
any spending bill that provides any more
money to Ukraine as the deadline
approaches so you've already got the
Pentagon saying doesn't matter Rand Paul
can stop whatever he wants we're still
going to fund the war in Ukraine I hope
that Republicans sign on to what Rand
Paul is suggesting here
Rand Paul is often the the lone voice in
the Senate and in part this is owing to
his libertarian Purity he doesn't he
doesn't want to give his Ascent to lots
of things that contradict his very
specific political ideology in this case
though I think that's a wonderful thing
in large part because what it will
reveal is that foreign policy is not
conducted by the Senate
it will just reveal
the political reality that people who
have been paying attention know but
people who think that the government is
just what you learned in fifth grade
civics class and the bill up on Capitol
Hill they don't realize
which is that
no the foreign policy a lot of domestic
policy too but the foreign policy in
particular
is conducted by people who are far less
accountable to you than your Senators
now that doesn't look very good for our
country and maybe you don't look very
good because you've got aging spots
which is why you got to check out
genucel right now go to genucel.com
Knowles as you might know we are big
fans of our friends over Virginia sell
don't just take my word for it Ella from
Rockford says quote I have age and acne
spots and this stuff is fading both of
them the serum is worth every penny
sunspots brown spots discoloration even
red inflamed patches all disappear in
front of your very eyes here's the genus
I'll guarantee
you will see results on day one or your
money back take advantage of geniusell's
most popular package which includes the
Dark Spot Corrector plus the classic
geniusl bags and puffiness treatment all
at about 77 0 off so you can try the
best skincare in the world for yourself
completely risk-free go to geniusell.com
start looking years younger tomorrow say
goodbye to dark and liver spots bags and
puffiness under the eyes crow's feet at
geniusell.comles that is geniusell.com
you know I especially love the founder
of this company who is a Coptic
Christian from Egypt who left Egypt for
the American dream and now brings a
great product to you genucel.com Knowles
speaking of Ukraine before I move off of
Ukraine
I think zelinski is just trolling us at
this point I think that Vladimir
zielinski at this point is just trying
to get Americans to root for Vladimir
Putin something that would have been
Unthinkable a few years ago but he's I
think he's trying
zelinski
hot on the heels of hiring a radical
American spokesman who as the military
spokesman for Ukraine was threatening to
kill American journalists
hot on the heels of that zielinski has
hired an actual witch to be his
ambassador
you might say Michael witches aren't
real first of all which is our real but
second of all even if witches weren't
real this is a woman
who does very explicit occult activities
of witches even even if you don't think
witches are real this woman does think
witches are real and zielinski just
hired her to be an ambassador to be a
face of the country it's not even like
hiring her to be the cook though she's
very good at Spirit cooking it's not
even like hiring her to go do some back
Office Accounting or something when you
are an ambassador you your entire job is
to be the face of your country to
represent your country around the world
or around various sectors and he's hired
a witch her name is Marina Abramovich
you've probably heard that name because
of the Wikileaks emails from the podesta
brothers remember Tony podesta very
powerful lobbyist and art collector and
all-around creep if you look into the
kind of art he collects and Affairs that
he's involved in and John podesta was
running Hillary Clinton's campaign in
2016 and there was a Wikileaks email
inviting John
from by by Tony to a spirit cooking
dinner led by
Abramovich and spirit cooking is just an
occult Satanic ritual
at the time the official fact Checkers
debunkers on the left they came out and
said
this is not a Satanic ritual we know
what it looks like it looks occult and
witchy and weird but it's not Marina
Abramovich is an artist and this is
merely a performance art piece that
happens to resemble and depict an occult
or Satanic ritual but Marina Abramovich
actually contradicted that herself I
haven't pulled up right here the quote
from Marina bromovic she she said in a
2013 Reddit q a
whether her occult Contemporary Art is
merely art or if it's an actual occult
ritual and what she said was everything
depends on which context you are doing
what you are doing if you are doing the
occult magic in the context of art or in
a gallery then it is Art if you are
doing it in a different context in
spiritual circles or private house or on
TV shows it is not art the intention the
context for what is made and where it is
made defines what art is or not that's
only half true I don't I don't actually
think that you can worship Satan
ironically and I do think that when we
engage in art that is occult and satanic
that actually does endanger our souls
but put that
spiritual Point aside for a second
let's just take her at her words the
spirit cooking that involved the
podestas the people running the Hillary
Clinton campaign was to take place in a
private apartment
so even by abramovich's own standards
they were engaging in witchcraft they
were engaging in an occult Satanic
ritual that was not merely art
which tells you everything that you
already knew about Hillary Clinton and
her Circle of Friends
but it also tells you a lot about
zielinski what the hell is this guy
thinking why is he trying to get us to
root for Vladimir Putin
I don't want to root for Putin but this
guy's making it really hard not to
and I can I can think of only two
explanations here
either
zielinski is involved in this stuff
either zielinski looks with a kind eye
on occult Satanic rituals or and this
might be even more distressing
zielinski knows that the American
conservatives don't want to give him
another Penny the only people who want
to keep funding his war or his I mean
say a charitably his defense of the
Russians which seems like a doomed
Endeavor anyway so the question as far
as I'm concerned is just how much longer
is this thing going to drag on
but regardless
zielinski knows that his bread is only
going to be buttered by the Democrats
and he thinks that the way to appeal to
Democrats is to hire witches to be his
ambassadors and I I guess that's worse I
guess the cynical read is even worse he
thinks well you know the only way to get
the American Democrats to support us is
to worship Satan and to get
which is to be the face of our country
that's that's a very sad thing
says even more about us than it says
about zielinski
speaking of weird stuff
hard pivot for a second there's a survey
out
that shows the three quarters of
homosexuals
believe that open marriages quote
unquote are acceptable
now an open marriage of course is a
contradiction in terms a marriage is a
lifelong Union
marriage properly understood is the
union of one man and one woman
who join together in a lifelong
commitment before God before the
political Community for the good of the
spouse is yes and ordered toward
the creation of children
that's what marriage is an open marriage
totally contradicts marriage but that's
still a phrase that people use and it's
one that three quarters of homosexuals
apparently agree with according to
a new Pew Research Center survey
75 of gay lesbian and bisexual Americans
find find open marriages acceptable
straight people oppose open marriages
most of them do at least 54 percent do
only 29 approve
the 29 is still way too high among
so-called straight couples
also known as normal normal marriages
but at least the vast majority of people
who I or the clear majority of people
who identify as straight
oppose such a thing so why is there such
a big gap here because don't forget
among the so-called straight people that
includes a ton of Democrats that
includes a ton of liberals that includes
a ton of people who have no problem with
so-called gay marriage that include you
know it's not just like radical
traditional Orthodox kind of people
and still a clear majority say this is
unacceptable whereas the vast majority
of homosexuals say that open marriage is
fine why is there a Chasm here
it's almost as if
we're talking about two completely
different views of marriage owing to two
completely different views of
anthropology it's almost as if the
radical redefinition of marriage by the
Supreme Court in the obergefell decision
was not merely the expansion of the
institution but the abolition the
beginning of the end for the institution
because the institution has a definition
and when you attempt to expand it you
reach an impossibility that does nothing
more but just then destroy the
institution that is obviously what took
place
I grew up in New York I went to the
gayest university in the United States I
lived in Hollywood a disproportionate
number of my friends have let's say
alternative sexual Views Little Light in
the loafers okay and
I I'd like to make clear I have no
phobias of any kind
love everybody
fair I'm a very
loving open-minded person but it is
simply a fact that the union of two men
or any Union of two women
is not and can never be the same thing
as the union of a man and a woman in
holy matrimony
it's just not possible
and
according to the survey
everybody knows it
the gays know it more than the straights
because they're saying yeah I don't
actually want like a
monogamous normal that's not that's not
how it works what are some of the
reasons for this one of the reasons
given in this article about Pew is that
while men have more testosterone and so
you know men have red blood men
generally when they're married don't
cheat on their wives and certainly
Endeavor not to cheat on their wives but
that's a restraining of their lower
impulses when you got two guys though
you both have those impulses unlike a
man and a woman where it's they men and
women just have different views of sex
it cannot be the same thing
and the the redefinition of marriage
which was sold to us is just you know
being intolerant and inclusive and nice
and why won't you just be open-minded
you bigot well no we're just saying
there's a point at which you're so
open-minded that your brain falls out
you have to acknowledge limits at at
certain points if a country doesn't have
limits around it it doesn't have a
border then it's not a country
if a concept doesn't have limits around
it it's not a concept it's undefined and
marriage certainly
if it doesn't have limits it it ceases
to be marriage as increasingly it would
appear to be the case
now one of my favorite concrete
expressions
of Love within my marriage is when I
come home and sweet little Elisa Cooks
me a good Rancher steak right now go to
goodranchors.com use code nulls we all
have a lot on our schedules you got the
kids baseball practice science fairs
prepping for the holidays well the good
news is you can take one big thing off
your plate by putting great meat on your
plate with good Ranchers
you care about what your family eats so
does good ranchers that is why they've
spent years building relationships with
local farms to Source the best 100
American beef chicken pork and now wild
caught Seafood too the best of the land
and sea can now get conveniently
delivered right to your door I love it I
had it last night I had some juicy
delicious rib eye I also just saw
our pal from good ranchers over at an
event in LA and I was able to secure
even more juicy pork that they're going
to be sending me and right now by the
way they're giving everybody two years
of free ground beef to anyone who
subscribes that's a 480 value no other
Meat Company guarantees you it's the
best it's the best quality on the market
it's an insanely low price you can lock
in your price it's ridiculous deal won't
last forever go to goodranches.com today
use code Knolls for 25 bucks off free
ground beef for two years subscribe to
any box to lock in your price
goodranches.com today use code Knolls
for over 500 bucks in savings subscribe
to good ranchers American Meat delivered
as you know the spooky season is rapidly
approaching
there will be demons out on the prowl I
guess there always are but we'll be more
conscious of it on Halloween I'm not
just talking about the world
corporations by the way that look upon
your values with disdain let's unwoke
Halloween
with your Army's chocolates
our delicious chocolate
comes in two forms you've got he him
with nuts
and she her nutless just as the good
Lord intended don't be a ghoul
head on over to Jeremy's chocolate.com
and order your chocolates right now in
time for Halloween
[Music]
turning our attention to the
presidential race
and actually I guess keeping our
attention on marriage and what happens
as a result of marriage you know that
usually creates children well the
abortion issue is front and center and
Nikki Haley has offered what I think she
views as an alternative between the
Stark take on abortion that you see from
the left and the Democrats and from the
right wing and the conservatives here's
Nikki's take
no Republican president can ban
abortions any more than a Democrat
president can ban these state laws
so why don't we just find consensus
can't we agree that we don't want
late-term abortions
can't we agree that we should encourage
adoptions and better quality adoptions
can't we agree that doctors and nurses
who don't believe in abortion shouldn't
have their performance
can't we agree that contraception should
be accessible
and can't we agree that no state law
should say that any woman who's had an
abortion can go to jail or get the death
penalty let's just start there
we have to humanize this issue I am not
going to be part of demonizing this
issue it's too personal to everyone and
the Fellas have done that for too long
no offense but it is time that we start
treating it like the sensitive topic
that it is
okay some of what Nikki said there is
correct some of it is not correct some
of it I agree with some of it I don't
agree with the part I really don't agree
with is when she says we need to stop
demonizing this issue
they're murdering babies they're
murdering little babies hundreds of
thousands upwards of a million per year
if we're not going to demonize this
issue
then I guess we're just denying demons
this is as demonic as it gets it's the
sacrifice of innocent little babies to
moloch okay that
that is that is as demonic as any issue
can get on planet Earth but
while I think that she is wrong
directionally on that point
I think Nikki is probably right
tactically on this point
because what she's saying is that
especially that first part she goes
we we've never had more than 45 pro-life
Senators actually hard strong pro-life
Senators so it's just not going to
happen guys you you're going to pursue a
national law to Outlaw all abortions and
it's not going to go anywhere and you
might feel really good about yourselves
by by saying well I stood firm for the
cause of life but the effect of it is
not going to be anything
because you're never going to get that
passed and there I think she's totally
right and it's it's something that the
conservatives and maybe the pro-life
movement aren't going to want to hear
but it's just a fact seems to me pretty
clear that federal law is a most likely
a dead end here
you could still have some kind of
federal rule on abortion but that would
come from the Supreme Court that's not
going to come from anywhere else
and it could come from the Supreme Court
I was just I flew out to LA just for a
night a couple days ago to the live
action Gala live action one of the
greatest pro-life organizations in the
country run by Lila Rose and live action
in the wake of the Dobbs decision over
ruling Roe v Wade
is said that the new North Star is 14th
Amendment jurisprudence
to say that not only as as some
textualists and originalists have said
in recent years not only is abortion not
in the Constitution not only should it
be returned to the States but one could
make a 14th Amendment argument and say
the 14th Amendment provides equal
protection under the laws
and I know that there are going to be
some people who say well the 14th
amendment was too broad it was intended
to address this problem of slave you
know slavery and what we do after
slavery is abolished but it was so broad
that it created certain problems within
the Constitution and I don't agree in
principle and it uh harmed the cause of
federalism and the cause of subsidiarity
and you can make all of those arguments
and I don't really even intend to
dispute them but it is a fact that the
14th amendment has
shaped the entirety of our jurisprudence
since then and the libs used the 14th
Amendment all the time to very bad ends
so here we could cite the 14th Amendment
for a very good end which would be
saving little babies and there have been
serious legal theorists people like John
finis people like Robbie George the
philosopher at Princeton who have made
this argument made it in an amicus brief
on the Dobbs case that the Supreme Court
should go even further and ban abortion
by reading the equal protection of the
laws into the 14th amendment that maybe
could go somewhere I'm still somewhat
skeptical of that too that maybe could
go somewhere but federal law is just not
going to happen
now speaking of presidential candidates
there is a shocking new poll
out of Washington Post and ABC which
shows that not only is Donald Trump
leading the pack in the Republican
primary he's also leading Joe Biden by a
lot
and this poll is shocking
according to the reaction to it and
according to some of the headlines but
it shouldn't be all that shocking if
you've been following the Washington
Post ABC Poll for the past number of
months so head to head
right now in a hypothetical 2024 matchup
Trump has 51 support to Joe Biden's 42
support
that's pretty big up nine points on
Biden
that this is good for Trump because he's
now up three points since the last ABC
Washington Post poll in February and
Biden is down by two points but those
shifts taken individually for the
candidates are actually not
statistically significant and even back
in February Trump was leading Biden
according to this poll from a liberal
Outlet there's even less change since
May the ABC post did the poll in May and
in may they had the race at 49.42 Trump
over Biden so everyone is so shocked now
but this is the way it's been for a long
time and then
just to put a button on it in in terms
of the primary right now Trump has 54
percent of Republicans and Republican
leading Independents compared to
desantis's 15 so he actually has taken a
pretty big hit the last time the poll
was done in May uh DeSantis had 25 now
he's down 10 points to 15 percent and
all the other candidates but DeSantis is
the only one with any even semblance of
a shot according to the post and ABC
every other candidate is in single
digits what do we conclude from this
we conclude I think that one argument
made by Trump's Critics on the right is
an absurd argument
and the art that is the argument that he
can't win the general
we hear this all the time from Trump's
Critics on the right
they say well if we nominate him
he cannot win the general and so we are
guaranteed to lose to Joe Biden or
whoever the Democrat nominee is
the people making this argument made the
same argument in 2016 which is why I
find the argument so absurd
we know for a fact that Donald Trump can
win the general because he did it at
least once
I say at least we'll leave it at that
we know that he can do that now does
this mean that I'm going to say he he is
going to beat Joe Biden again this time
no I'm not saying that
in fact I'm not even saying I think it's
likely that Donald Trump would be Joe
Biden this time
my reason being
rigged the election in 2020 they very
clearly rigged it even if you don't
think that the rigging resulted in
Trump's laws
even if you think Biden would have won
anyway it is simply a fact they changed
a huge portion of the election rules
right before the election to favor Joe
Biden that's just a fact and so if we
can't unrig that sort of thing then
Trump very likely might lose again
but if that's your conclusion
then there is no reason to believe that
they wouldn't rig it against any of the
other Republicans Ron DeSantis Vivek
ramaswamy Nikki Haley Tim Scott any of
them Chris Christie of course the
chrysosons
so in that that's not really an argument
against Trump that's an argument against
our democracy as it presently stands but
you can't use that as a primary argument
because that would be an argument from
the structure of how the elections are
held and it and by the way if if your
argument is simultaneously that the
Democrats really fear Ron DeSantis or
some other candidate more than Donald
Trump then you've got even less of a
point here because then there's no
reason to believe the Democrats wouldn't
rig the election any harder any any less
hard against the other guys
now
is the election hopelessly rigged I mean
do you really believe that that
Republicans have no shot whatsoever I'm
not willing to say that
we've done a good job certain Republican
Governors including Ron DeSantis
actually have done a good job of undoing
some of the rigging within their own
States so I am cautiously hopeful that
2024 will be less rigged than 2020.
cautiously helpful about that
and also the Trump campaign is showing
that it's getting a little bit more
serious about working in the Nitty
Gritty details
of these election rules itself we're
seeing this in the primary
one of the reasons that Trump is doing
so well
in the the 2024 primary
is not merely that he is good at
appealing to people and the the broad
survey say people generally like him
one of the other reasons this just came
out really good report on this a few
days ago
is that the Trump campaign is going in
to the individual State parties and
fixing the rules to give him an
advantage
one GOP Observer says parties are
extremely keen on being more important
in the primary that's why we're seeing
more winner take all rules and seeing
more early primaries or caucuses when
they have the opportunity what that
amounts to is a front runner set of
rules
something that benefits the front runner
and delegates being allocated quickly
Josh Putnam whose political scientist
says the Trump team was unusually active
in nudging state parties toward changes
for 2020 that one made it easier for
Trump to gobble up delegates as a
nominating process moved through the
calendar of contests and two made it
much more difficult for multiple
candidates to win delegates another
Republican lawyer Ben Ginsburg says the
Trump campaign succeeded in changing
rules quote in part because they knew
what they were doing and in part because
everyone else is asleep at the switch so
I I don't think this is exactly
favorable about Trump I think the point
of the article was to say they're
rigging it and they're not giving the
other candidates a chance this actually
makes me feel much better about a
potential Trump nomination which right
now seems quite likely I don't the
numbers in as much as they're moving at
all are moving in Trump's favor and away
from his opponents so if he is the
nominee the question is can he win I I
don't know I don't know I wouldn't bet I
wouldn't bet a lot of money that Trump
beats Biden but hearing things like this
I'm beginning to think oh maybe maybe he
will have a better shot maybe his
campaign is actually doing the
nitty-gritty things on the ground to
make sure that they don't steal the
election in in elections
campaigns and especially the Democrats
are always trying to steal things
I've seen this I've worked on campaigns
this is why we have poll Watchers the
whole reason that poll Watchers exist is
because we know that people try to steal
elections and they bust in voters from
out of district and they try to loosen
voter ID rules and they try to bribe
people and they do all the things that
you heard about Boss Tweed and the old
Tammany Hall political machines doing
all the things that you've heard in
democracies for all of human history
okay they try to do them here every
election sometimes it's easier and
sometimes it's harder
and in 2020 it was much much easier
because we turned election day into
election month and we had widespread
mail-in ballots and we had ballot drop
boxes that were often illegally far away
from where they were supposed to be and
we had the infusion of Zuck box and you
had you had the government answering to
private entities that had a very liberal
agenda and you had pipes bursting in
Georgia and you had days and weeks weeks
of ballot counting in some cases a
pausing of the vote when it looked too
good for Donald Trump there was just so
much rigging and I am hoping that the
Trump campaign
realizes that
the election is going to be won or lost
there okay yes you need a good campaign
yes you need to persuade people but look
at the polls Biden is very unpopular
right now and Biden would appear to be
much less popular than Donald Trump so I
think the popular support is kind of
there already
the question is will the will the
popular sentiment really matter in terms
of the final election no that election
is going to be determined underneath
bursting pipes can the Trump campaign
patch up those bursting pipes in order
to make sure that the count matches
public sentiment
my favorite comment on Fridays from
Dominic zelenak who says
I can name three branches of government
BlackRock State Street and Vanguard very
perceptive
fairy that was a
perspicacious sort of thing to say
speaking of our elected officials before
we go this destroy I meant to get to on
Friday we'll get to it now
John Federman
the senator from Pennsylvania who is now
dressing like a plumber onto the on the
floor of the United States Senate and
actually had checks remember change the
rules for him John Federman
broke down crying on the floor of the
Senate because I live in a political
environment I was ridiculed and made fun
of because I wasn't able to process this
thing sometimes or say things think so
I'm so sorry that I'm sure many of you
had to go through this kind of thing you
know I was lucky that I was
I was lucky enough to go through my life
the vast majority of that without this
kind of disability that I have but um
but again I can't imagine and how the
the challenges and I and I admire you
know everyone that has to kind of live
with these kind of struggles and and and
Prevail over them
I have a great deal of sympathy for John
fetterman I'm not going to
join the chorus of people just making
fun of him for crying
I'm sure he's in a great deal of pain I
have no doubt that he sincerely was
depressed when he was checked in for
depression at that medical center and
I bet he's going through a lot
it's very difficult
he
he is not fit to be a U.S senator
and he's in this role and that is not
conducive to flourishing personally for
him or nationally for us
I'm I'm not making fun of him I'm not
calling him all sorts of names it pains
me greatly when people feel bullied and
uh insulted and low about themselves it
pains me I hate that I hate seeing that
I I
really feel for the guy I sincerely feel
for the guy the solution to that is for
him to resign he is not fit for the job
if if he can't figure out how to put on
a a jacket
If he if he can't conduct the basic
business of the Senate
this is not the place for him
and he got himself elected Senator and
that's great and that's an
accomplishment but
the circumstances of his life are such
that he is not fit for this job if the
job of Senator still matters at all I
guess this this is what ties in with the
first part that we were talking about
today which is does the senate ratify
treaties does the senate conduct War
does the senate or declare war rather
does the senate really do the business
of government or is the Senate just kind
of a facade is it a little bit of a club
that works around the margins and
approves judges and has some modicum of
power but is the business of government
really conducted more in these agencies
by unaccountable faceless bureaucrats
who don't really need to worry about
government shutdowns who don't really
need to worry about elections who does
is the Senate just kind of a joke
the longer that John fetterman remains
in the U.S Senate even with the
pressure to do what little power the
Senate has
or to wield what little power the send
has is going to be very hard on him and
he's probably going to cry more and he's
probably going to break down more and
that's a sad thing
but also the longer he remains in the
senate in this condition the clearer and
clearer it is
that the Senate is not what we once
thought it was
it's the government happens elsewhere
speaking of broken institutions
is a leaked video out of the Veterans
Affairs Department
it promotes abortion
and it says the pregnancy is not limited
to women
person who is pregnant is more inclusive
language however many of the studies
that exist today have not so far
included trans men or non-gender binary
people identified as such hello my name
is Emily ashba my pronouns are she her
and hers and I'm really glad to be with
you today some patients may be fearful
distrustful or have preconceived beliefs
related to reproductive health care
which may impact their decision making
based on their own experiences and the
long history of reproductive Injustice
in this country
language has a profound impact on what
people hear and learn
when discussing abortion please use
these examples of clinically accurate
language
there are many ways the VA can provide
abortions including on-site with
providers ordering prescription
medications or performing abortion
procedures in outpatient clinics and
operating rooms where available
if you were only listening on the radio
or on podcast
you didn't see even the craziest Parts
where they'll it just writes out right
in this VA PowerPoint not everyone who
gets pregnant is a woman don't use the
kind of language baby or unborn child
you have to say embryo or fetus don't
say chemical abortion let's say
medication abortion yes that's what we
want don't say womb don't say womb
say uterus
don't say mother say veteran or person
don't
deal with the reality of this
a related story back to the Senate is
that Senator Tommy tuberville right now
is holding up the appointment of various
people to the higher echelons of the
military because of this crap because
the military is now pushing funding for
abortions and to allow service members
to travel out of
wherever they are to go get abortions
and and uh contradicting state laws that
are pro-life and saying no no we're
going to make sure that if our employees
are in your state they're going to be
able to kill their kids and Tommy
tuberville Senator trevorville pointed
out this is not
helping the fighting force of the United
States this is not important important
to the mission of the US Military and I
am not going to allow any of these
people to get their new appointments
until you cut this out and he's being
lambasted for it and this guy is a hero
man Tommy tuberville is a hero and
deserves all of our support and I
recognize here that the Pentagon and the
VA are distinct they're pretty clearly
related and they clearly share the same
infanticidal insane ideology
and we absolutely need to grind this to
a halt until they stop this I want our
US military to kill our enemies I don't
want the US military to kill our own
children that's a terrible thing and
anybody who's complicit in this in the
military needs to be thrown out
and anyone who wants a new hire
appointment in the military needs to say
no we're not going to do this anymore
this is a major cultural problem
this cuts to the very core of who we are
as a country and what our country is
fighting for and I think Tommy
tauberville is doing great and I think
every other Republican senator and any
Democrat Senator with a conscience
should join him in this
this is this is a much deeper problem
than oopsie Daisy some little regulation
passed through the Pentagon but don't
hold up our appointments for it no no
this is
a a clearly essential view a sacramental
priority of our present ruling class
that has infected now the military and
we've got to cut out that infection
before moving on and allowing the
military to address other challenges
absolutely good job Senator tupperville
let's get we need some tupperville's for
the VA too the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member today and use code noltz
kwles to check out for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]